En este video quiero demostrarte que existen
un montón de números irracionales y además
que siempre entre cualesquiera dos racionales,
cualesquiera dos racionales que tú te tomes,
podemos encontrar un irracional.
Así que vamos a verlo primero de una manera
visual para que tú entiendas a que me refiero.
Imagínate que aquí tengo una recta numérica,
ok...
va para acá... va para acá... ok...
e imagínate que yo me tomo dos números irracionales,
los números irracionales que yo quiera,
se me antoja tomarme éste de aquí, va a ser
mi racional número 1, ok, me voy a tomar
otro racional por aquí, éste, va a ser mi
racional número 2, ok,
cuales sean los dos racionales que yo me tome,
entre ellos siempre va a existir un irracional...
siempre va a existir un irracional...
y justo eso es lo que quiero ver en este video,
que entre cualesquiera dos racionales,
existe un irracional
y no forzosamente tiene que estar
justo en este punto,
puede estar en cualquier parte
entre estos dos racionales.
Y eso es bastante impresionante, porque fíjate
que nosotros sabemos que tenemos un buen de
racionales, ahora, si nosotros sabemos que
tenemos un buen de racionales, de hecho tenemos
una infinidad de racionales, bueno, pues en
medio siempre de cualesquiera dos racionales
podemos encontrar un irracional, lo que quiere
decir que hay una infinidad también de irracionales,
son un montón.
Ahora, para llegar a la demostración de
justo esto que te estoy contando,
que te parece si empezamos con un
intervalo que conozcamos muy bien,
me voy a tomar el intervalo de 0 y 1.
Es decir, 0 nosotros sabemos
que es más chico que 1...
bueno, déjame ponerlo por acá...
aquí voy a poner a 1...
a 1...
Ok y si yo te pregunto
si existe algún irracional entre 0 y 1,
seguramente tú me vas a decir que si lo hay,
un ejemplo es 1 entre raíz de 2...
1 entre raíz de 2, que es exactamente
lo mismo que raíz de 2...
raíz de 2 entre 2, que por cierto,
es aproximadamente...
y bueno, es aproximadamente
porque es número irracional...
es aproximadamente 0.7071067811...
y muchos decimales más,
recuerda que como es un irracional
tiene una infinidad de decimales,
pero bueno, esto es lo que es
aproximadamente raíz de 2 entre 2
y este número claramente está entre 0 y 1,
así que ya sabemos que existe al menos uno.
Y por lo tanto, lo voy a poner aquí,
raíz de 2 sobre 2...
mejor lo voy a poner como
1 entre raíz de 2, bueno,
al menos ya sabemos que en el intervalo
0 y 1 existe al menos un irracional
que es justo éste de aquí.
Ahora, basándome en esto
que ya sabemos,
en el intervalo 0 a 1, voy a construir un
irracional que esté justo entre estos dos
racionales, así que para eso quiero que te
des cuenta de algo muy importante,
si yo me tomo "r", el racional 2 y a esto le quito...
a esto le quito...
déjame cambiar de color...
le voy a quitar el racional 1...
el racional 1, bueno,
pues esto es mayor que 0,
esto es más grande que 0
y nosotros nos podemos dar cuenta precisamente porque así nos estamos tomando estos dos racionales,
estamos diciendo que "r2" es más grande que "r1".
Ok, pero éste de aquí me va a servir bastante,
porque ahora voy a multiplicar todo por justo
esto que está aquí, voy a multiplicar la
parte derecha y la parte izquierda por esta
diferencia de racionales que tengo aquí.
Y por lo tanto me va a quedar...
vamos a ponerlo así...
0...
Oh no, espera...
déjame cambiar de herramienta...
me va a quedar que 0 por éste de aquí,
por "r2" menos "r1"...
que lo voy a poner justo por aquí,
ok  y los voy a poner multiplicando así que...
déjame tomar este color...
0 que multiplica a estos dos,
ok, esto es menor...
y sabemos que la desigualdad se conserva porque
tenemos un número positivo y como tenemos
un número positivo las desigualdades se conservan...
esto es menor que 1 entre raíz de 2...
1 entre raíz de 2, ok, esto que a su vez
multiplica a éste, porque recuerda que voy
a multiplicar todo por esto...
entonces...
déjame ponerlo que lo estamos multiplicando...
para esto déjame agarrar aquí, este color
y los voy a pasar multiplicando y esto a su
vez es menor que 1, 1 por estos de aquí,
lo voy a poner así, que 1, 1 por...
vamos a ponerlos aquí...
otra vez por estos dos de aquí...
Ahora, date cuenta que 0 por "r2" menos "r1",
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 0,
por lo tanto podríamos quitar esto de aquí...
déjame quitarlo...
lo voy a quitar, ok...
y solamente quedarnos con 0,
esto es 0.
Y por otra parte, aquí tengo 1 por estos de aquí,
así que mejor déjame quitar esto de aquí...
voy a quitar esto de aquí...
y solamente voy a poner "r2" menos "r1", ok,
que es justo lo que nosotros queríamos,
"r2" menos "r1".
Ahora, esto ya se va pareciendo un poco a
un número irracional que esté entre estos
2 y si te das cuenta, lo que nos falta es
aquí tener "r2" y aquí tener a "r1",
así que qué te parece si sumo a "r1" de todos
los lados de esta desigualdad,
voy a sumar a "r1" aquí, aquí también voy a sumar a
"r1" y aquí también voy a sumar a "r1",
de tal manera que 0 más "r1" me va a quedar
solamente "r1", mi racional 1,
que por cierto me lo tomé
de una forma aleatoria,
esto es menor ¿que quién?,
bueno pues aquí me queda,
"r1"...
"r1" más 1 entre la raíz de 2...
1 entre la raíz de 2...
que a su vez multiplica a "r2" menos "r1",
que a su vez multiplica
a lo que teníamos aquí...
ok, perfecto, éste lo voy a poner aquí y
voy a cerrar mi paréntesis,
así que déjame poner esto de aquí
y voy a cerrar mi paréntesis...
y de este lado, del lado derecho me va a quedar
"r2" más "r1" menos "r1", de tal manera que
éste y éste se van y solamente me queda "r2",
entonces del lado derecho
me queda solamente "r2".
Ahora, date cuenta de lo que estoy diciendo,
estoy diciendo algo muy importante,
que entre "r1", es decir,
entre este racional que me acabo de tomar
y "r2" este racional que me acabo de tomar,
estoy construyendo un irracional
que está en alguna parte entre ellos dos.
Ahora, lo padre es que "r1" y "r2",
los tomamos de manera arbitraria,
son cualquier par de racionales
que tú quieras
y este número de aquí,
este número de aquí es un número irracional,
¿y cómo podemos ver eso?
Bueno, porque "r2" menos "r1", éste, es un
número irracional y recuerda que un número
irracional cuando lo multiplicamos por un
número racional...
éste sabemos que es irracional...
un racional por un irracional, me da un número
irracional, así que todo esto de aquí es
un número irracional
y si a esto le sumamos un número racional,
llegamos a un número irracional.
Justo en los videos pasados,
hemos probado
que cuando nosotros sumamos un
racional con un irracional me da un irracional
y cuando nosotros multiplicamos
un irracional por un racional,
me da también un irracional.
Así que, esto de aquí es irracional...
irracional, que es justo
a lo que yo quería llegar,
a que en el intervalo entre "r1" y "r2"
exista  al menos un irracional,
que es este de aquí.